[Music]
mildly penis OV what are you finding
here
what subreddits are you on so these are
just things
it's like like kind of look like someone
has a penis sticking out probably a
penis
was that in Disney font hold on you just
kind of skipped past yeah
why yeah well I think it's because maybe
the animators just put dicks in things
but what are those ones
I'll leave it it's mildly vagina just a
bunch of sandwiches
[Laughter]
kind of funny actually
also when it's when it's a vagina it's
funny and when it's a dick it's funny
yeah that ain't mildly penis scroll up
that's that's mildly [__]
actually now that's mildly uncut yeah
yeah that vein read it man all right
that's mildly come
that's frosted come
Dang if you jizz in the cold is that
what it turned into
like you know when people throw hot
water yeah yeah if you just shot some
rope into like minus two
there's gotta be a turned about already
of that
[__] in minus 40.
it just turns into baby powder yeah whoa
wow baby powder
yeah hey ah nice yeah hey hey who said
we were done with mildly P
yeah okay wait a way to denigrate Easter
the sacred holiday you want to make it
about sitting on things
[Laughter]
I mean people post here daily that's
crazy penis is showing up mildly in
public there's a bunch of guys that
they're just Joss Whedon
guy on the right his shirt what you
don't see it
the face you don't see someone's sucking
a dick oh my god oh damn oh my God damn
I was seeing the you know the other side
yeah
I thought that that was just Josh weed
and putting his dick out
that's what I say it's just like a bunch
of guys in trench coats
in public parks
all right
grandmother oh it's supposed to be
candles
I mean that's more dick than anything
else yeah like all right man
beating the sun is horny dude
yeah his son is beating down yeah
[__] in Plus 40.
[__] at a hundred
what would happen if boil it's the same
thing would happen it's turned into
steam yeah yeah
dude
the sun's penis is hot as hell bro
the future's gonna be a dark place when
it's so hot and you can't even come
can't even be solid bro what
[Laughter]
that is so funny
that is genius
Popper's got a dick butt
oh I'm having fun with this now
I am the group bro I am hung that's
funny
I mean all right where is that
Dubai yeah I kind of just take a piss
man
yeah all this dick talk all this mild
dicks
let's see a quick break
and we're back sorry all this penis got
me uh did you poop huh
like you were in there blasting music
yeah yeah for 10 minutes yeah at least I
thought I was going in for a for a
Whizzer but then
my stomach was like hey hold up oh okay
so did you start peeing first and then
yeah so then you had to turn around and
or were you were you were you setting to
pee okay so I
was gonna whiz
and then I said [__] it let me get two
in one
but but honestly ridiculous I want to be
ridiculous for a second
in high school sometimes after you know
the city bus takes a long ass time to
get home so you're usually primed for a
[__] so there were days where
I had both
and I would start taking a piss and I
would be like could I just
and I would slip one foot out of my
jeans
and I would just try to acrobatically
sit into a [__] while pissing
yeah like you would step over oh dude
it's easy you point your dick down it's
easy
yeah and then you could just kind of
like
now then you just piss oh yeah okay okay
I'm out the pants yeah yeah right right
I was only successful like a couple
times so you were unsuccessful every
other time no no I've only attempted I'm
like I mean it's a dangerous maneuver I
think my record is like it's kind of
like a three for three situation
wow
yeah that's a I might try that I mean it
takes a lot of Bounce You Gotta like sit
in yeah and a lot of focus has to be the
right because as you're gonna be having
a good dick day too yeah yeah
yeah
yeah you know oh you know for for almost
hanging just right yeah feel confident
you know yeah like I think it's I think
today's the day you kind of got to sit
in as you pivot around and it has to be
the right amount of like having to take
a poop too like not too much because
then it's just
you know yeah I mean I mean like the
real Alpha [__] is like you you like
you're pissing you cut the valve you're
like hold on hold
sit resume no no the real no the real
Alpha that's to continue piss no it's to
sit to pee and then stand up in 180 to
[__] yeah
yeah while you're peeing I just let it
let it just squeeze out your ass
so graphic dude yeah because that way
you pee on yourself the toilet and you
[__] all over the stall door yeah yeah
that's the most Alpha yeah
yeah and then you 180 again sit back in
your own pee on on the C and pee onto
the [__]
so funny to just Aces later yeah I mean
you really have to go
it we really should piss and [__] like
AC Slater like yeah everyone jokes about
that move but that's actually how
toilets should be what's the move like
when you sit reverse and you like prop
your arms up on the rear that's how they
should be it should be an armrest yeah
truly like you should be able to like
one hand like on the phone yeah look at
Tick Tock you're just pissing and [__]
yeah yeah no it should be one of those
like airplane massage seats yeah
you know what I mean
you're sitting and you're putting your
face like that
or like the at the airport I mean yeah
or or in the mall you know
or it could be like almost like an OB
GYN like there's like stirrups
like you like kind of crawl up into it
and then you like your legs and then
you're kind of tilted back so you'll be
on your phone yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah and it's extracting your poop yeah
yeah
now you put a little suction cup on your
wiener and it's just
so you can piss up
we're Engineers man yeah we really are
Engineers we really are